I am sitting in a 2017 Ford Mustang this
has an automatic transmission it's going
to use the five button proxy eat now
this is for the like the fusion style
the older ones 13 to 15 also works on
the newer style so there's no difference
so we're just going to do an add
products to this right first thing we
want to do we want to connect
ignition is off we want to add a key
so you need two keys available for
programming it's only on a clear now
you're learning port is right in the
middle the second cup holder closest to
the cubby let's go ahead stick that
thing down there
face-first leave it right in there we're
going to go ahead and hit yes to
continue we only need one key now we're
going to do the bypass usually says it
takes up to five minutes but in most
cases I found out it's less than a
minute
okay turning town just a second that
should say it's okay there you go
granted no go ahead okay Keith program
to and first key into the slot that's
ready in there
okay door locks click plug your point I
heard it or in hit okay keys program
three so we know that's good let's go
ahead go back to our menu we're going to
go down to the bottom in disconnect
alright this point we're done we're
disconnected from the communications
port we're going to press our button
here and we're going to power off so now
we're essentially disconnected now
there's our prongs take it on out of
there you can hear working I'm gonna put
my foot down on the brakes and our start
button is right there right there result
we are back in business
the flickering lights down there that's
just into the shutter speed of the
camera is about like that
we are all then